I don't know whether you were just
dating or whether you just got married
but there was a Christmas when you
really dropped the ball oh god yes
it was our fur it was our first
Christmas as a married couple so we go
back to her family's place in Colorado
we're gonna spend Christmas there with
them and leading up to what I said to my
wife I said well what do you want for
Christmas and she said nothing nothing
nothing and I said no no but really well
what do you want for Christmas she said
nothing and I made the mistake of
believing her then Christmas day good
news everyone
so then Christmas morning everybody's
opening presents were giving presents to
the kids for her parents for her
siblings significant others everyone
gets presents and all the sudden I see
my wife kind of looking around noticing
that there's really nothing for her and
then she looks at me and I go what she's
like okay and then everyone finished
doing the present thing and we went
downstairs and she just started crying
and she was like this is our first
Christmas as a married couple with my
parents what is not you told me nothing
you believe
now I know as a man who's been married
almost nine years now that you all
speaking code understand I'm still not
fluent but I think I'm getting that yeah
you're married right yes you're married
and you ever make the same mistake no
not here
[Applause]
right under that one if I was six up
five and Hollywood actor I don't think
she'd mind
[Laughter]
[Music]